president Trump delivered a campaign
style speech in Pensacola Florida last
night and rallied support for embattled
Alabama Republican Senate candidate Roy
Moore it was mr. Trump's 35th rally in
Florida since he first began his
campaign for the presidency in 2015 the
president is spending the weekend at his
Florida resort but he plans to travel to
Mississippi today for an event that will
be boycotted by two members of Congress
Errol Barnett is with the president in
West Palm Beach Florida
Errol good morning good morning
president Trump was in his favorite
setting last night in front of an
adoring crowd and his speech touched on
familiar themes you had your predictable
villains and heroes he attacked the
media joked about his election opponent
Hillary Clinton but most importantly for
the president he listed issues he says
have made his first year in office a
success unlike any other we're going to
cap off an incredible first year in
office start speaking to a roaring crowd
in Pensacola
president Trump delivered of victory
style speech flaunting his policies and
reminding the crowd it is now America
first the president highlighted
November's positive employment report
and boasted about the number of jobs
created during his time in office we've
created more than 5 trillion dollars in
new economic wealth just in the stock
market alone for over an hour mr. Trump
listed campaign promises he says he's
fulfilled urging supporters to give him
another ally in the Senate by voting for
Alabama's ROI more in next week's
special election the future of this
country cannot afford to lose a seat in
the very very close United States and we
can't afford it for it and while he
wasn't afraid to again endorse Moore's
controversial run the President did
avoid mention of an issue awaiting him
today these guys look at these guys
blacks for Trump I Love You mr. Trump's
decision to travel to Jackson
Mississippi were an unexpected snowstorm
as frozen the city is causing an angry
backlash the president plans to deliver
remarks to civil rights veterans before
the opening
of the new Civil Rights Museum creating
friction with several african-american
lawmakers this is not the time for to be
a photo-op for President Trump who has
no civil rights record
Mississippi's Democrat congressman
Bennie Thompson is joining Civil Rights
icon Congressman John Lewis in
boycotting the event in a joint
statement the lawmakers said quote
president Trump's attendance and his
hurtful policies are an insult to the
people portrayed in this Civil Rights
Museum
now Jackson's Democrat mayor will join
Lewis and Thompson in protesting the
opening ceremony all of them citing
president Trump's disrespect of civil
rights activists in response the White
House says it is unfortunate lawmakers
are skipping the event they say still
president Trump will honor the sacrifice
of civil rights leaders Anthony Errol
Barnett Thank You Errol